let's see if we can simplify six to the
one-half power times
the fifth root of six and all of that to
the third power i encourage you to pause
this video and try it on your own
so let me actually color code these
exponents just so we can keep track of
them a little better so that's the
one-half power in blue this is the fifth
root here in magenta
and let's see in green let's think about
this third power
so one way to think about this fifth
root is that this is the exact same
thing as raising this six to the one
fifth power so let's write it like that
so this part right over here we could
rewrite as six to the one fifth power
six to the one one-fifth power and then
that whole thing gets raised to
the third power
that whole thing gets raised to the
third power and of course we have this
six to the one-half power out here
six
to the one-half power times all of
all of this business right over here
now what happens if we raise something
to an exponent
and then raise that whole thing to
another exponent well we've already seen
in our exponent properties that's the
equivalent of raising this to the
product of these two exponents so this
part right over here could be rewritten
as
this part right over here could be
rewritten as
six
to the three times one-fifth is
three-fifths six to the three-fifths
power
six to the three-fifths
power and of course we're multiplying
that times six to the one-half power
six to the one-half power times 6 to the
3 5th power and now if you're
multiplying some base to something to
this exponent and then the same base
again to another exponent we know that
this is going to be the same thing and
actually we could put these equal signs
the whole way because these all equal
each other this is the same thing as six
being raised
to the
one-half plus three-fifths power
one-half plus three over
three
over five now what's one-half plus three
over five well we could find a common
denominator it would be ten
so that's the same thing as actually let
me just write it this way this is the
same thing as six to the
instead of one half we can write it as
five over 10
plus 3 fifths is the same thing as 6
over 10
to 6 over
10 power
which is the same thing and we deserve a
little bit of a drum roll here this
wasn't that this wasn't that long of a
problem six to the eleven tenths power
six to the others right and all that 11
over tenth
power
and so
that looks pretty simplified to me
i guess we're done